movie fans might have noticed that
jackie chan has appeared in fewer and
fewer american films throughout the
years
after he became one of hong kong's
biggest and most profitable silver
screen stars thanks to his work as an
actor and stunt man in martial arts and
action movies
it seemed inevitable that chan would
take over hollywood in 1998 he took a
giant leap toward that feat when he
scored a role in his first big
international blockbuster rush hour
playing opposite chris tucker in the
action comedy film
chan became instantly recognizable to
fans all across the globe
from there he followed up the first rush
hour with a handful of sequels and many
other american projects like the spy
next door
all three kung fu panda movies and a
2010 remake of the karate kid starring
jaden smith
it's undeniable that chan is one of the
biggest stars in the world but he's
largely disappeared from the american
spotlight though he's still churning out
films in his native hong kong here's the
real reason jackie chan stopped filming
american movies
in an october 2020 interview with
filmalia which was translated into
english by movie web chan revealed the
reason why he's been sticking to movies
made in asia lately
as he told the outlet i've never left
america but i haven't been able to find
the right script
unfortunately for chan he seems to get
pigeonholed a lot
chan referenced the seven year gap
between 2010's karate kid in 2017's the
foreigner co-starring pierce brosnan and
said
all these years after the karate kid i
received so many scripts but the role is
always a hong kong policeman that's why
it took me seven years to accept a role
in another hollywood film with the
foreigner
i said can i have something different
like
mamma mia ultimately chan wants to
diversify his roles and get into more
dramatic work during the same interview
chan explained that his roles in the
karate kid and the foreigner are the
type of parts he's seeking out these
days
in the karate kid chan played a
maintenance man who's actually a kung fu
master
he becomes the mentor to a 12 year old
boy who recently moved to hong kong and
wants to learn to defend himself
chan's role in the foreigner was just as
interesting he played an ex-special
forces operative who became a
restaurateur in london following the
vietnam war
however when his teenage daughter dies
in a terrorist bombing
chan's character seeks revenge these
parts in hollywood films allowed chan to
explore new territory which is something
he wants to do more of on screen
if the right hollywood movie script
comes along chan would presumably jump
at the chance
that just hasn't happened yet as he told
film alier i want to make sure that
every year the audience can see
so many different sides of jackie chan i
would like audiences to consider me as
an
actor who can do action not just as an
action star
i don't like to repeat myself this isn't
the first big announcement chan has made
about the future of his career
at the 2012 cannes film festival the
icon admitted that he was stepping away
from action movies
he revealed i will ask my body how long
i can go
i tell you i am not young anymore i am
really really tired it also
isn't the first time that chan has
discussed his desire for audiences to
see him as more than just an
action movie star during the cannes film
festival press conference for chinese
zodiac in 2012 the actor shared that he
wanted to show the world the real
jackie chan to do that chan's plan was
to move away from action-heavy roles
and into more dramatic territory he
explained i don't just want to be an
action star i want to be a true actor i
want to be an asian robert de niro
i want to get rid of my image so for the
last 10 years i've done
other films like the karate kid where
i'd rather play an old man
i want the audience to know i'm not just
about fighting or comedy
also i can act with all this considered
chan also recently teased a fourth rush
hour movie so it seems that nothing's
off the table just yet
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite celebs are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one